[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هي ثلاثه وجوه ثلاث لغات وثلاثمائه وخمسه
وستون يوما من الحرب ربما اختلاف اللغات
جعل التواصل معقدا والنتيجه صراع دموي
مستمر منذ عام نظريا هو بين دولتين لكن
عمليا كل العالم تاثر كل العالم
[موسيقى]
الممثل الكوميدي حافظ على دور البطوله لكن
مصرحه اليوم بمساحه تفوق 600 الف كيلو متر
حيث يستحوذ دور البطوله في اوكرانيا كلها
ساحه قتال مستعره منذ عام على الارض
يقابلها مواجهه
بينسكي للخلفيه الفنيه
واحد من اكثر رجالات العالم حنكه بالسياسه
والحروب
بعد شهر واحد من انتهاء عرض مسلسله خادم
الشعب والذي جسد فيه دور الرئيس الاوكراني
شاءت الصدف ان تعطي الممثل الكوميدي
فلودوميرزلينسكي فرصه الدوري نفسه لكن في
الواقع عام 2019 ليصطدم بعد ثلاث سنوات من
حكمه باختبار انهكه سياسيا وجسديا
قائد بزمن حرب بمواجهه فلاديمير بوت
السياسي المحنك والعميل السابق في
المخابرات السوفيتيه لنحو عقدين
غريمه ليس بسهل وقواته تحتل المرتبه
الثانيه عالميا كاقوى جيوش العالم فجوه
بين الرجلين كانت واضحه منذ اول لقاء
بينهما في باريس خجل اوكراني واستمتاع
باضواء سياسيه دوليه للمره الاولى يقابله
استخفاف وغطرسه روسيه وفق محللين
رئيس غير متمرس تخلى عن ربطه العنق ليتسح
باللون الاخضر العسكري معتمدا على قاعده
شعبيه كبيره واتقان فن التواصل المباشر مع
الجمهور لم يتحصن في كييف بل بات دائما
التنقل بين خطوط المواجهه ويحل كل حين ضيف
شرف في دول عظمى وبرلماناتها ويحظى بدعمها
سياسيا وماليا وعسكريا
وما كان يتصوره الرئيس الروسي معركه يومين
لا تزال مستمره منذ عام وابطئته عسكريا
واقتصاديا غير ان الحرب اخرجت بوتين اكثر
عنادا وعدوانيا وحرف z المنقوش على
دباباته تخطى مقوله زابوبيدا اي من اجل
النصر بالروسيه يرتدي اسم زيلينسكي
هذا واكد نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي
الروسي ديمتري ان موسكو ستنتصر في
اوكرانيا وكتب على تطبيق تيليجرام سنحقق
النصر مضيفا ان الهدف هو دفع حدود
التهديدات الى ابعد ما يمكن حتى لو كان
ذلك حدود بولندا وفق قوله
نفس النصر الذي تحدث عنه اكده الرئيس
الاوكراني زيلينسكي لكن لبلاده 2023 سيكون
عام النصر بعد سنه من الالم هكذا يرى
اوكرانيا العظيمه قبل عام في مثل هذا
اليوم من هذا المكان نفسه حوالي الساعه
السابعه صباحا
خاطبتكم ببيان المنجز استمر سبعا وستين
ثانيه فقط سنلزم كل التهديدات من قصف
وقنابل وصواريخ طائرات كميكازي بدون طيار
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي البرد نحن اقوى
من كلها لقد كان عام التحمل عام الرحمه
والشجاعه عام الالم عام الامل عمل مثابره
عمل وحده عاما لا يقهر عمن شرسا لا يقهر
استنتاجه الرئيسي اننا جوله لبنهزم وسنفعل
كل شيء للفوز هذا العام
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسل
اتفقت مع ما قاله زيلنسكي اوكرانيا ستنتصر
في الحرب
اوكرانيا اصبحت اقوى من اي وقت مضى
اوكرانيا اصبحت بشهاده الامه اقوى
اوكرانيا لن تتوانى في سعيها للحصول على
الحريه لقد شهدنا ذلك في كل يوم من بين
ستنتصر لان الاوكرانيين لن يتراجعوا ابدا
اوكرانيا ستنتصر لان اوروبا وشركائها
وحلفائها سيقفون بكل قوه الى جانبها
اما الامين العام لنيتو يانسوسدد على ان
الحلف سيتافع عن كل شبر من اراضيه
قبل عام الرئيس بوتين غزا اوكرانيا بطريقه
عدائيه وغير قانونيه وخرق كافه القوانين
الدوليه بوتين اراد كسر عزيمه الشعب
الاوكراني ووحدتنا ولكنه فشل ولكننا نؤكد
اننا سنحمي كل شبر من اراضي الحلف كما
نشدد على ان الناتو والاتحاد الاوروبي
سيقفان الى جانب اوكرانيا دائما لان
انتصار بوتين في الحرب اكبر خطر على امننا
نبدا المتابعه في هذه الساعه من تغطيه
العربيه للذكرى الاولى لاندلاع الحرب في
اوكرانيا من كييف ومن سكول لندن منفردات
العربيه ليالي الاختيار من مراسل العربيه
عبد الجواد الرشد ومن لندن مصطفى زارو
مرحبا بكم جميعا ابدا معك انت في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه التي تستذكر هذه الليله قبل
عام كيف تبدو لك المواقف كيف يستذكر
الاوكرانيون هذا اليوم يوم اندلاع الحرب
في بلادهم ووصول القوات الروسيه الى ارضهم
صهيب اسمح لي يعني ان نقول اننا بوسط
العاصمه تحديدا من يعني من هذه النقطه
ورائي هو وسط العاصمه كياف التي اليوم
يعني شهدت حركه طبيعيه بعكس ما كنا نتوقع
ومكان الاوكرانيين يتوقعون كانوا يتوقعون
صواريخ كانوا يتوقعون ان يكونون في
الملاجئ اليوم ولكن اتت الصوره مغيره
ومعاكسه هدوء تام حياه طبيعيه هناك يعني
نوعين من الخوف موجود عند الاوكرانيين
الخوف الاول ان تنتهي هذه الحرب لصالح
روسيا وهذا ما لا يريدونه ابدا الخوف
الثاني ان تكون هذه الحرب طويله الامد
طويله على حساب الاوكرانيين وعلى حساب هذا
البلد من دمار وخراب ولكن هناك قناعه
ثابته بان هذه الحرب فرضت عليهم وبالتالي
هم سيكملونها حتى النهايه ايضا يعني من
الجانب الاخر من جانب المسؤوليين المس
الاوكران ومن جانب السلطات الرسميه هناك
ثقه بالدعم الغربي وهناك قلق القلق نابع
يعني من انهم يريدون ان تكون الدفعات
اتحدث عن دفعات السلاح عن دفعات الدعم
بالمال ثابته ومنتظمه بالمرحله المقبله
نظرا للتحديات الدفاعيه التي تواجهها
اكياف واوكرانيا طبعا ونظرا ايضا للتحديات
الاقتصاديه وغير التي تواجهها العاصمه بظل
كل ما يحصل من حرب على الجبهه نعم هذا عن
العاصمه الاوكرانيه ليان نذهب الى منسك
عاصمه بيلاروسيا الحليف الوثيق لروسيا في
هذه الحرب كما ذكرت ليال عبد الجواد
الاوكرانيون يخافون ان تنتهي هذه الحرب
لصالح روسيا او ان تستمر لسنوات طويله
ماذا عن بيلاروسيا كيف تبدو بعد عام على
انطلاق هذه الحرب
مساء الخير صهيب لك والي الزملاء نعم
بالفعل يعني ايضا انا اقف في مركز العاصمه
البيلاروسيه مين طبعا مينس لم تعد اليوم
كما كانت عليه قبل عام من الان قبل بدء
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه هذه البلاد الذي التي
تعتبر حليفه موسكو الاستراتيجي الاول
العسكري والاقتصادي والسياسي في كل
المواقف طبعا لابد من لفت الانتباه صهيب
الى ان طبعا الشعب البيلاروسي يعتبر انه
يعني سقط مقابل قضيه او ملف الاخ الاكبر
وهو موسكو لذلك طبعا لاحظ بان الاتحاد بين
موسكو وميسك وضع الشعب البيلاروسي في مازق
اليوم باعتبار ان العقوبات تطال كل الداخل
البيلاروسي الوضع كما نرى من خلف في مدينه
ميسك هو هادئ نوعا ما المدينه تعيش حياتها
الطبيعيه لكن خط الخط الحدودي الفاصل ان
كان بين الاراضي البيلاروسيه والاراضي
الاوكرانيه او الاراضي البيلاروسيه
والاراضي البولنديه هو متوتر نوعا ما يشهد
يعني حشودا من القوات الاوكرانيه
البيلاروسيه والقوات الروسيه بالاضافه الى
معدات ثقيله طبعا بيلاروسيا كانت قد تحدثت
بانها يعني لن تكون
اراضيها مكانا للدخول نحو الاراضي
الاوكرانيه من قيل في هذه النقطه نعم
لم تتعرض لضربات من تلك نعم ساعود اليك في
هذه النقطه يعني ان كانت بيلاروسيا ستشارك
في السنه الثانيه من الحرب ام لا نذهب الى
لندن مصطفى انت امام السفاره الروسيه في
لندن ما هي اهم الفعاليات الشعبيه
والسياسيه كذلك في هذه الذكرى السنويه
الاولى لاندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا
البدايه صهيب كانت من من مقر مقر الرئاسه
في
حيث عقد رئيس الوزراء رفقه السفير
الاوكراني في لندن بالاضافه الى عناصر من
القوات الاوكرانيه التي يتم تدريبهم هنا
في المملكه المتحده بدقيقه صمت وايضا هذه
الدقيقه صمت يعني ثلاثه ترديد شعار النشيد
الوطني الاوكراني بالاضافه الى ان مجلس
العموم يعني توقف خلال هذه الدقيقه الصمت
يعني للتذكير بهذه المعاناه التي يمر بها
الشعب الاوكراني بالاضافه الى تداعيات هذه
الحرب ليس فقط على على اوكرانيا فحسب ايضا
على العالم وخاصه هنا في المملكه المتحده
انا اتواجد امام السفاره الروسيه كما ذكرت
وهنا عدد من
الناس اتوا لايصال رساله الدعم للشعب
الاوكراني وايضا مح يعني تقديم بعض بعض
الرسائل الى الى موسكو هذا بالاضافه الى
ان امس مثلا تم الطلاق هذا الشارع امام
هذه السفاره اللولين
الاصفر والازرق وهو لون العالم الاوكراني
نتوقع ايضا ان تصل المسيره انطلقت من امام
السفاره الاوكرانيه في لندن وتاتي هنا الى
السفاره الروسيه في لندن
لترديد شعارات وايضا انتقاد السياسه
الروسيه
باتباع مواصله حربها على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه هذا بالاضافه الى ان الملك
تشارلز اصدر بيانا يصرف فيه الشجاعه الشعب
الاوكراني
ووقوفها ضد هذه الماسي التي شهدنا على مر
السنه ولربما يعني رساله قويه ان الشعب
البريطاني يقف جانب الاوكراني في معاناته
تحت الاله العسكريه الروسيه مصطفى طبعا
يعني شكرا لك على هذه الصوره الحيه
اللونان الازرق والاصفر حضران بقوه في
لندن كما نشاهد معكم العلم الاوكراني في
هذه الذكرى الاولى لاندلاع الحرب عبد
الجواد كنت وعدتك ان اعود اليك في عجاله
لو سمحت هل هناك مؤشرات على ان بيلاروسيا
ستدخل الحرب في عامها الثاني
رسميا صهيب بيلاروسيا تتحدث بانها لن تقوم
بالتحرك عسكريا باتجاه الاراضي الاوكرانيه
في حال لم تتعرض لاي هجوم من تلك الاراضي
لكن طبعا بسؤال العربيه للوكاشينكا الرئيس
البيلاروسي اجاب بانه في حال طلبت موسكو
من جديد استخدام الاراضي البيلاروسيه او
الاجواء البيلاروسيه للتقدم نحو الاراضي
الاوكرانيه فستقوم بتقديم هذه الاراضي الى
موسكو زملائي الاعزاء من
لندن عبد الجواد رشد ليالي الاختيار
ومصطفى زار شكرا جزيلا لكم على انضمامكم
الينا في هذه الساعه
[موسيقى]
وفي جلسه مجلس الامن قبل قليل طلب وزير
خارجيه اوكرانيا الوقوف دقيقه صمت حدادا
على القتل الاوكرانيين خلال الحرب ليرد
عليه المندوب الروسي بطلب وقوف دقيقه اخرى
على القتل الروس وواجه المندوبه الروسيه
مقاومه في البدايه من وزراء خارجيه دول
الغربيه الا انهم وقفوا في النهايه نتابعه
اطلب الى الجميع فضلا الوقوف دقيقه صمت في
ذكرى ضحايا العدوان الروسي شكرا سيدي
الرئيس
يطلب الكاميرا ده
روسيه الكلمه
السيد رئيس
وقفنا لنحيي ذكرى كل ضحايا ما جرى في
اوكرانيا بدءا من العام 2014 كل من قضوا
فكل حياه لها قيمه ولهذا سبب نقف لنحي
ذكرى الجميع
[موسيقى]
اشكر
الممثل
باخر الاخبار العاجله اذا لدينا تصريحات
خاصه
للعربيه من البيت الابيض اذن البيت الابيض
يعتبر ان اي طفاق سلام يجب ان ياخذ بعين
الاعتبار سياده اوكرانيا
والبيت الابيض كذلك يقول ان المعلومات
تشير الى ان الصين بصدد تقديم دعم عسكري
لروسيا يضيف كذلك البيت الابيض للعربيه
بوتين لم يتخلى عن مطامح السيطره الكامله
على اوكرانيا
وطبعا معلومات تشير الى ان الصين ليست
بصدد تقديم دعم عسكري لروسيا اذا يقول
البيت الابيض ايضا في نفي اذا لموضوع
تقديم الدعم العسكري الصيني
لروسيا اذا ليست بصدد تقديم دعم عسكري اذا
لروسيا طبعا للتذكير ان الصين طرحت يعني
خطه سلام للوساطه اذا بين روسيا واوكرانيا
على العموم نواصل التغطيه ايضا المشاهدين
في هذه الساعه نستقبل الان من باريس
باتريس باولي ان ننطق باللغه العربيه باسم
الخارجيه الفرنسيه ساعه السفير اهلا بك
معنا في العربيه الحرب في اوكرانيا اذا
تدخل عامها الثاني
هل تغير موقف باريس من هذه الحرب في هذه
المرحله
شكرا لهذا السؤال اولا اودن
اقول كلمه عن
اوكرانيا والعالم ككل
فتركيز اليوم على اوكرانيا طبعا وهذا
الشيء طبيعي لكن هذا لا يعني لا نحتم بما
يجري في يحصل في العالم من هروب
وازمات واريد ان نكرر تضامن فرنسا مع شعب
سوري مع شعب التركي بعد الكارثه التي حصلت
في هذه المنطقه
وتضامننا مع كل المفقودين والدعايه
والجرهم فيما يتعلق باوكرانيا طبعا لم
يتغير الموقف الفرنسي منذ البدايه وما
اعلنه اول يوم
كامل على الهواء انا مضطر لمقاطعتك لناخذ
هذه الكلمه المباشره لمندوب الصين في مجلس
الامن الى هناك الى نيويورك والموضوعيه
وتتلافى كل تسييس
كل دوله مسؤوله عن مهمه
تنميه تنميه المحليه وبالتالي نعرف ان
للازمه الانسانيه الاثار على المدى الطويل
ولكن هذه الدول المتاثره ليست طرف النزاع
وبالتالي يجب ان تتكبد ثمنا عاليا بسببها
تقوم بعض الاطفال باستعانه بتدابير احاديه
والضغط باعلى المستويات لكن ذلك لا يساوي
المساله بل يقوض سلاسل الامداد اكثر ويزيد
من حده الازمه الماليه والغذائيه وازمه
الطاقم نامل ان الاطراف ذات سوف تتخذ
تدابير مسؤوله ولا تستغل هذه التدابير
الاحاديه اما مبادره تصدير الحبوب في
البحر الاسود والاتفاق بين الامم المتحده
وروسيا حول تصدير المواد الغذائيه
والاسمده فتتسم بكل الاهميه بما يضمن
الامن الغذائيه عبر العالم ويجب ان تنافذ
بشكل كامل وفاعل وبشكل متوازن ايضا سيدي
الرئيس
لن يكون درب للسلام باليسير ولكن بغض
النظر عن مدى تعقيد هذه الظروف يجب الا
نفقد امالنا بالسلام او نوقف جهودنا من
اجل السلام بشان المساله الاوكرانيه تقف
بلادي دائما الى جانب السلام والحوار ونحن
جاهزون للعمل مع الاطراف جميعها بما يعزز
حلا سياسيا للازمه الاوكرانيه وبما يؤدي
الى احلال السلام في اقرب الاجار شكرا
جزيلا
اشكر ممثله الصين على هذا البيان واتيح
اذا مشاهدينا نكتفي بهذا القدر من كلمه
مادوب الصيني في مجلس الامن
وتحدث بان الصين لا يجب ان توقف الجهود او
العاجه العالم لا يجب ان يوقف جهوده
لاحلال السلام في اوكرانيا وقال كذلك ان
درب السلام لن يكون يسيرا اذا في اوكرانيا
اذا لكن نعود مره اخرى اذا لكلمه لممثل
السياسه الخارجيه اذا في الاتحاد الاوروبي
وعلى مر السنه راينا جميعا
شجاعه الاوكرانيين نصره لبلادهم وهم
يستحقون التضامن من الجميع عبر العالم من
كل دوله ومن كل شخص
وضد ان اركز على نقطتين اثنتين اليوم
لماذا تعنين هذه الحرب التي اختارتها
روسيا وثانيا كيف
نصل الى السنه
[موسيقى]
مزقه الاسر
وفي طيف من الجرائم راينا ترحيلا قصريا
لعشرات الاف الاطفال
راينا اختطافا لاطفال اوكرانيين ابرياء مع
تغيير لوضعهم الشخصي بما في ذلك الجنسيه
حتى يتم تبنيهم من اسرى روسيه وفي ذلك
انتهاك واضح لقانون حقوق الانسان والقانون
الدولي وفي ذلك انتهاك كذلك الاتفاقيات
جنيف
هؤلاء الاطفال الاوكرانيون لابد من ان
يعادوا الى اوكرانيا فورا
ثم جرائم ضد الانسانيه انا زرت بوتشا
ورايت بامي العين مدنيين يقتلون
بعضهم مقيده يديهما
المشاهدين نكتفي بهذا القدر من كلمه
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي هو
يتحدث في جثه المجلس الامن عقب كلمه
المندوب الصيني الصين التي قدمت مبادره
الاحلال السلام والتوسط بين روسيا
واوكرانيا
باختصار ما قاله لحد الان بان هذه الحرب
اخترتها
عن الاطفال الاوكرانيين الذين جرى نقلهم
الى روسيا لتبنيهم من قبل روء عائلات
روسيا كما قال بوريل اذا اعود الى ضيف
باريس باريس باولي سعاده السفير اعتذر لك
مره اخرى على مقاطعتك كنت مضطر كي اذهب
الى نقل كلمه اذا المجلس الامن كنت تتحدث
عن موقف الحكومه الفرنسيه من هذه الحرب هل
سالتك هل تغير من بدايه الحرب الى الان
على عام على مرور هذه الحرب او اندلاع هذه
الحرب في اوكرانيا
لا ابدا لم يتغير منذ البدايه كان موقف
فرنسا واضح هذا ما اعلنه منذ اول يوم
الحرب الرئيس ايمن الماكوم دعم لاوكرانيا
التي
يتعرض
ليعطينا
متعمد لا مبرر له من روسيا
ونحن ندعم كاملا دعما حتما
لاوكرانيا للدفاع عن نفسه طبقا لميثاق
والمتحده لكن
في البدايه في البدايه الرئيس ماكرون كان
يعني يلعب دورا وسطيا نوعا ما كان هناك
اتصالات هاتفيه عديده بين الرئيس ماكرون
والرئيس فلاديمير بوتين في بدايه الحرب
وكان هناك حديث على دور فرنسي
لايجاد يعني نقطه في المنتصف لانهاء هذه
الحرب مبكرا والان نسمع كلاما عن توجه
فرنسا لتقديم لمدرعات واياميكس وكذلك
صواريخ ايضا الى الجانب الاوكراني هذا ما
يدفعنا للاعتقاد هل فقدت فرنسا الامل في
انهاء هذه الحرب سلميا او في الوساطه مع
روسيا لانهاء الحرب
اولا لم يتغير مثلا مره اخرى الموقف
الفرنسي نحن نؤمن كفرنسا نؤمن بالحوار
الحوار لكن على الحوار ان
يكون مفيد له مضمون ومعنى اليوم
ضروريه الوقت هي
مسانده كامله الدعم كامل على كل للساده
سياسي عسكري تجاري
اقتصادي انساني لاوكرانيا اذا لم يتغير
موقفنا اليوم
ماذا
قد نعمل
نزود اوكرانيا بالعتاد المعدات التي تحتاج
اليها منذ البدايه عملنا كذلك ونجاوب على
الطلبات التي تقدم الحكومه الاوكرانيه لنا
نعم
من هي هذا هذا الدعم فيما يتعلق بنهايه
الحرب كلنا نامل في في نهايه الحرب لكن
على الاوكرانيين ان يهددوا
معايير او ظروف شروط حل سلمي حل لهذه
الحرب هذا المسؤوليات اوكرانيا ولكن ما هي
المقاربه
هذا بالنسبه للاوكرانيا لكن ما هي
المقاربه المناسبه التي تراها فرنسا
مناسبه لانهاء هذه الحرب كيف يمكن انهاء
الحرب في اوكرانيا سعاده السفير
ليس لنا مسؤوليه تحديد شروط
انتهاء الحرب هذا يعني مسؤوليه
الاوكرانيين لذلك نحن
ندعمسكي بعشر نقاط هي قاعده لحل سلمي حل
نهائي لهذه الحرب فليس لنا مسؤوليه لتحديد
معايير هذه الانتهاء نعم اشكرك شكرا جزيلا
الاجابه على اسئلتنا وحضورك معنا في
العربيه هذا المساء من باريس سيد فتره
باللغه العربيه باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه
نذهب الى فاصل بعدها ونستكمل هذه الساعه
من تغطيه العربيه الخاصه للذكرى الاولى
لاندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
بين التكتيك والاستراتيجيه كثيره كثيره
كثيره كانت التحركات العسكريه على الجبهات
الاوكرانيه بدا الروس حربهم ب 190 الف
جندي كانوا وقود المعارك المشتعله قبل
الاضطرار لاعاده تعبئه الجزئيه في اكتوبر
الماضي ليصل عددهم الى 220 الفا واليوم
التقديرات تشير الى 330 الف عنصر بين جنود
وقوه انفصاليه ومتطوعين وطبعا مرتزقه
وكانت كيف كانت التحركات طوال السنه
الاولى من الحرب الاجابه مع زميله حنين
طويل لدى بوتين واطول منه لدى الاوكرانيين
وبنهايته ابتعدت جدا احلام العوده الى
الشهر الاول من الحرب الاوكرانيه الرابعه
عشر من مارس روسيا تستولي على 27% من
اوكرانيا اكثر من ربع بلاد من الجنوب
بمساحته الزراعيه الشاسعه وتحديدا في
خرسون الى الشمال محطه شرنوبل بري يصل الى
حافتكييف كانت هذه ذروه النجاح الروسي ومن
قمته جاء السقوط الحر في ابريل الى قاع
الفشل على ابواب العاصمه الاوكرانيه انسحب
الروس من شمال وشمال شرق اوكرانيا في
الثامن من ابريل لتبدا المرحله الثانيه
كما اسماها بوتين بخساره اربعين في المئه
من مكاسب الميدان من مايو وحتى نهايه
اغسطس خطوات بطيئه في الشرق حققت مكسبين
ماريوبول نهايه
لم يستشعر بوتين في غمار محاوله جيشه
السيطره على دنيا العاصفه القادمه من
خركيب العاشر من سبتمبر اكبر تقدم للجيش
الاوكراني في يوم واحد على حساب انسحاب
الروس في الشمال الشرقي باكثر من 50 كم
والمساحه تحمل اهميتها انسحب الجيش الروسي
اوكرانيا مكاسبها من هجومها المضاد
مسترجعه وخمسين في المئه من اراضيها لكن
الحرب رمال متحركه في الخامس والعشرين من
يناير الماضي القوات الاوكرانيه تنسحب من
صولدار شرقا بعد اقتحام قوه فاجنر
المعادله العسكريه الروسيه بقوه وتصدرها
مشهد الحرب في اعقاب التباطؤ الشتوي
المكسب مهم سوليدار بدرجه اقل المكسب
الحقيقي على بعد عشره كيلو مترات ولاجله
سجلت اكثر المعارك دمويه في الحرب مخموض
في دنيا هي الحصن على حد وصف الرئيس
الاوكراني فولدمير زيلينسكي والبوابه
الوحيده للروس في تقدم سيطرتهم على
المقاطعه الانفصاليه محمود تفتح الطريق
نحو مدينتي كراماتورسك وسلوفيانس
الرئيسيتين تشكلان مع مقاطعه لوغانسك
الحوض الصناعيه الكبير في اوكرانيا
ارسلت بولندا اليوم دفعه الاولى من دبابات
اثنين من اصل 14 دبابه كانت قد وعدت بها
اوكرانيا اعلن رئيس الوزراء البولندي
ماتيوس مورفسكي عن ارسال الشحنه الاولى
خلال زيارته الى كيف تزامنا مع ذكرى بدء
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
وكانت بريطانيا والولايات المتحده وفرنسا
اعلنت تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات في حربها
في المقابل اعلن وزير الدفاع البريطاني
بين ولصنا بلاده لم تقوم بتزويد اوكرانيا
بمقاتله تايفون في المستقبل القريب واضاف
طائرات المقاتله سيتطلب ارسال مئات
الاشخاص بينهم مهندسون وطيارون مشيرا الى
ان الغرب لا يرسل قوات الى اوكرانيا بهذا
الحجم لكن يمكن ان ترسل بريطانيا 200 شخص
من السلاح الجو الملكي في وقت اخر وليس في
هذه المرحله
اطراف وحرب اوكرانيا تعد عدتها لخوض حرب
الدبابات الثقيله في الربيع والصيف
المقبلين والكل يتحدث عن حرب طويله وفي
خضون العام الاول من هذه الحرب يعتقدوا
حلف النيتو ان روسيا فشلت تماما في تحقيق
اهدافها
في نهايه عامها الاول تدخل حرب اوكرانيا
منعطفه معركه الدبابات الثقيله التي تدفع
بها الدول الغربيه الى سهوله اوكرانيا بعد
تزويدها بمختلف المضادات وانظمه الدفاع
الجوي اليات غربيه تبدو في عين موسكو
مقدمه لاعاده معركه ستالينغراد قبل 80
عاما
اطلقت روسيا حمله غزو شامله ضد اوكرانيا
حيث فجرت اكبر نزاع في اوروبا منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه ولا نرى اي مؤشر على
استعداد روسيا للسلام
اقتحام القوات الروسيه ترابا اوكرانيا في
شهر فبراير العام الماضي دفع حلف شمال
الاطلسي الى مضاعفه قدراته العسكريه في
دول السفع الشرقي وفق مقرراته قمه النيتو
الاستثنائيه
لم يكن يوما اطلاقا موحدا مثل ما هو الحال
علي اليوم بوتين يواجهه بالضبط عكس ما
يتوقعه جراء ما فعله في اوكرانيا
حلف الناتو نشر اربعه كتائب قتاليه في كل
من المجري والسلوفاكيا ورومانيا وبلغاريا
تضاف لاربع كتائب منتشره منذ خمس سنوات في
بولندا ودول البلطيق الثلاث
دول الحلف وضعت اربعين الفا من القوات
الخاصه تحت امره النيتو واستنفرت 130
طائره ومئه واربعين سفينه حربيه من مياه
الشمال البارده الى المتوسط الدافئ مرورا
بمياه البحر الاسود الولايات المتحده من
ناحيتها نشرت 100 الف جندي في اوروبا
قبل نحو عام توقع بوتين ان تكون اوكرانيا
هدفا سهلا بوتين توقع سقوطك بسرعه وتوقع
ايضا ان العالم سيقف غير مبالغ الكرملين
اخطا حساباته كافه
حرب اوكرانيا تدخل عامها الثانيه وسط
السباق حربي محموم بين روسيا واوكرانيا
مدعومه من دول النيتو بين دوله قد تستخدم
السلاح النووي اذا تعرضت للهجومي ودول
بعضها نوويه تمتلك احدث الاسلحه
حان الوقت للعوده الى الوراء والتعامل مع
الوضع ب واقعيه وبالنسبه للقول اننا
سننتصر في هذه الحرب لا احد سينتصر الوحيد
الذي ينتصر في هذه الحرب والذي يتمكن من
وقفها ومحاسبه المسؤولين عنها
دول ناشئه عده قادره على الاطلاع بدور
الوساطه لانهاء حرب مدمره اذا قبلت اطراف
النزاع وتنازلت عن شيء من كبريائها روتين
الفريد العربي بروكسل
ونشر المشاهدين الى هذا الخبر العاجل نقلا
عن الوصيه جورنال المانيا وفرنسا
تطالبنسكي بالتفكير جديا بمفاوضات السلام
نتابع مع الدكتور رياض قهوجيه الكتب
والبحث في شؤون الامن والدفاع معنا هنا في
استوديو العربيه دكتور رياض اهلا بك معنا
الحرب في اوكرانيا اذا تدخل او تبدا عاما
ثانيا هل هذا العام 2023 سيكون عاما حاسما
لانهاء هذه الحرب ام ربما هذه الحرب
ستستمر سنوات من الصعب التحدث منذ الان عن
الحسم يعني الان نشاهد كلا الطرفين يحضر
لهجمات وهجمات مضاده كلا الطرفين يتسلح
اوكرانيا تتوقع استلام اكثر من 300 دبابه
خلال الاشهر القادمه مع كم كبير من
المدافع والذخائر وربما طائرات هذا العام
لا نعلم يعني امور عديده وضعت خط احمر
عليها الدبابات سابقا الان بدات مسموحه
وبالتالي كل شيء مات وارد واضح ان كلا
الطرفين مصمم على ان لا يصلح الطرف الاخر
بالفوز دكتور انوه الى هذا الخبر العاجل
ويبدو لافتا رئيس الاوكراني
يعلن نيته او عزمه لقاء الرئيس الصيني
والصين طرحت بالامس يعني خطه من 12 نقطه
على ما اعتقد لي انهاء الحرب والتوسط بين
روسيا واوكرانيا الان رئيس يقول انه يعتزم
لقاء الرئيس الصيني هناك اشياء متناقضه مع
هذه الذكرى الاولى للحرب دكتور رياض من
جهه كما تفضلت هناك تسليح من الجانبين
استعدادات لحرب كبيره وفي نفس الوقت نرى
مؤشرات ربما على انهاء هذه الحرب او وساطه
صينيه لانهاء هذه الحرب هل يعني ستكون
هناك معركه الربيع الكبرى ام سيكون هناك
مفاوضات سلام من وجهه نظر اي طرف ملمبي
فنون حل
والتفاوض في الحروب لا يمكن الدخول في
مفاوضات من موقع ضعيف كده الطرفين يريد ان
يظهر انه في موقع قوه
الاعلان عن مد اوكرانيا في هذا كم من
الاسلحه ومدها في هذه الاسلحه هو وضع
اوكرانيا في موقع قوه يسمح لها الدخول في
مفاوضات من موقع قوه ومن هنا
لن يرفض اي فرصه للمفاوضات طالما يشعر انه
في موقع قوه
مع هذا الكم من الاسلحه والدعم من الغرب
في نفس الوقت روسيا سترحب باي مفاوضات
تعطيها فرصه للتنفس
لتحسين وضعها
وبما ان المبادره تاتي من طرف ذا ثقه
كروسيا بالنسبه للصين من الصين بالنسبه
لروسيا فلابد لروسيا ان تقبل بهذه
المبادره طيب ولكن دكتور ما الذي يرضي
الطرفين يعني تبدو المسافه متباعده ما
الذي بالنسبه لكل طرف ما هو النصر
حسب قوانين واصول المفاوضات في حل
النزاعات
تبدا عمليه الوصول لحل عندما يقتنع
الطرفان بان الحرب قد حققت اقصى ما يمكن
تحقيقه في هذه الحاله فقط يصبح طرفان
مستعدان لتقديم التنازلات والوصول الى حل
بعد عام من الحرب
روسيا ماذا حققته اوكرانيا ماذا حققت
اوكرانيا حققت انها بقيت
صامده استعادت جزء كبير من اراضيها روسيا
لم تحقق سوى السيطره على بعض الاراضي انما
فشلت في تحقيق اهدافها الاستراتيجيه
وبالتالي هي اليوم لا تستطيع وقف الحرب من
جانب واحد لانها ستبدا كانها خسرت
وبالتالي طالما ان احد الطرفين مقتنع بانه
يستطيع ان يحقق المزيد من النصر لن يكون
هناك مجال لمفاوضات ناجحه نعم طيب في
المقابل الروسي يتهمون الغرب بانه يريد
هذا الصراع وهو الذي اطال امد هذه الحرب
يعني لولا الغرب يعني لما كانت استمرت هذه
الحرب اكثر من ذلك هل تعتقد ان هذا صحيح
طبعا لولا الدعم
الامريكي ودعم النيتو لما استمرت هذه
الحرب وفي نفس الوقت يعني علينا ان نعلم
ان الناتو لن يسمح لروسيا بالانتصار لاني
اوكرانيا في اوكرانيا لانه السمحوا لروسيا
في الانتصار في اوكرانيا يهم يخشون انها
الاستقرار
لحرويه الثانيه لسيناريو هتلر عندما سيطر
على على بدا يسيطر على دوله اخرى من
النمسا ومن ثم الى بولندا
مره اخرى لكن نسمع اصواتا تقول انه الغرب
يعني حتى ليس لمصلحه اوكرانيا نفسها يعني
هو يعطيها سلاح لدرجه انه
للدفاع فقط يعني ليس لتحقيق النص ليس
لمهاجمه روسيا ليس للانتصار على روسيا بل
كي تستمر هذه الحرب طويله ما رايك في هذا
لا لا اعتقد النوع الاسلحه التي تعطى لها
هي لتحقيق مكاسب داخل اوكرانيا هو لا يريد
ان يعطي قوه او قدره لاوكرانيا بان تستطيع
بضرب داخل في عمق الاراضي الروسيه لان هذا
يؤدي الى تصعيد كبير من الجانب الروسي قد
يؤدي الى حرب عالميه ثالثه ومن هنا تريد
الغرب يحدد انواع الاسلحه بحيث ستمكن
القوات الاوكرانيه من الصمود منع روسيا من
احتلال المزيد الاراضي وتمكينها من تحرير
اراضي اضافيه داخل اوكرانيا وليس اكثر من
ذلك شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور رياض قهوجي على
التربيه دوله العربيه هذا المساء شكرا
مشاهدينا فاصل قصير نستكمل بعده هذه
الساعه من تغطيه المستمره الحرب التي غيرت
العالم ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد اوضحه سيده اوكرانيا
الاولى اولينا زيلينسكا في مقابله حصريه
مع قناه العربيه هي الاولى من نوعها مع
وسيله اعلام عربيه اوضحت ان زوجها
اقترح خطه سلامين من عشرين نقاط لتحقيق
الضمانات الامنيه معربه عن امرها في
التوصل الى استقرار وامن دائمين في بلادها
لكي نكون اكثر هدوءا لبلدنا اقترح الرئيس
زيلينسكي خطه سلام من عشر نقاط نحن بحاجه
الى ضمانات امنيه اذا كانوا كذلك فيمكننا
ان نامل في سلام طويل الامد ومستقر
وهذا التصريح اخر للرئيس زيلينسكي عن
الصين يقول ان الصين تحترم وحده اراضي
اوكرانيا قبلها كنا ذكرنا لكم مشاهدينا في
الخبر العاجلنسكي عربه عنيته او استعداده
للقاء الرئيس الصيني الصيني التي قدمت
مبادره سلام للتوسط بين روسيا واوكرانيا
لانهاء الحرب وبالحديث عن السلام عدت
الصين اذا مشاهدينا خطه لذلك ترتكز على
مجموعه من النقاط ابرزها تطبيق ميثاق
الامم المتحده الخاص باحترام سياده الدول
ونبدا عقليه الحرب البارده ووقف القتال
تفاصيل هذه الخطه الصينيه في سياق التقرير
التالي
خطه السلام الصينيه في اوكرانيا تقوم على
12 نقطه في مقدمتها تطبيق مبادئ ميثاق
الامم المتحده الخاصه باحترام سياده الدول
وعدم استخدام القوه والتهديد بها لضم
الاراضي ونبذو عقليه الحرب البارده هو عدم
السعي لتحقيق الامن القومي على حساب امن
الدول الاخرى والاهتمام بالمشاكل الامنيه
لكافه دول اوروبا الخطه ترتكز ايضا على
وقف القتال والصراع والتحلي بضبط النفس
تفاديا لتاجيج النزاع مع اطلاق مفاوضات
سلام وفتح باب الحل السياسي في اسرع وقت
ممكن الازمه الانسانيه لها حيز من الخطه
عبر دعم وتشجيع كافه الاجراءات التي تساهم
في تخفيف ازمه المدنيين وحمايه الاسرى
الخطه تدعو ايضا للحفاظ على سلامه المحطات
النوويه وتقليل من المخاطر الاستراتيجيه
من خلال معارضه استخدام الاسلحه النوويه
والكيماويه والبيول وجيه خارطه الطريق
الصينيه تدعو لضمان نقل الحبوب وتنفيذ
مبادره البحر الاسود وكذلك بالتوقف عن فرض
العقوبات احاديه الجانب مع ضمان استقلال
سلاسل الصناعه والامداد والحفاظ على
النظام الاقتصادي العالمي القائم لتخلص
الخطه لدعوه المجتمع الدولي الى الدفع
باعاده الاعمار بعد نهايه النزاع بلال
البجداني العربيه
يلقى الدعم الامريكي لاوكرانيا تاييد
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين في الكونجرس
ويتجلى من خلال تمرير مجلس الشيوخ والنواب
حزم المساعدات العسكريه الكياف والمطالبه
بتسريع ايصالها وبارسال اسلحه اكثر تطورا
خاصه من قبل الجمهوريين لكن هذا لم يمنع
وجود شخصيات جمهوريه معارضه لهذا الدعم
الامريكي لاوكرانيا غير المحدود
دعم امريكي مفتوح لاوكرانيا في معركتها ضد
روسيا هو ما اكده الرئيس جو بايدن خلال
زيارته
سنبقى معكم سيد الرئيس طالما ان الامر
يتطلب ذلك صدى كلمات بايدن تردد حتى من
قبل الغزو الروسيه في اروقه الكونغرس
الامريكيه الذي يؤيد باغلبيه اعضاء حزبيه
في المجلسين الشيوخ والنواب دعم اوكرانيا
مسانده ترجمت بتمرير حزم بعشرات مليارات
الدولارات كمساعدات عسكريه وغير عسكريه
ناشد الرئيس
الاوكرانيس بتقديم المزيد منها خلال
زيارته لواشنطن في ديسمبر الماضي اؤكد لكم
ان الجنود الاوكرانيين يمكنهم ان يشغلوا
الدبابات الامريكيه بشكل مثالي الا ان هذا
الدعم السخي يواجه اصواتا جمهوريه معارضه
حيث حذر رئيس مجلس النوابه كبن مكار في
قبل انتخابات التجديد النصفي بان حزبه لن
يوقع شيكا على بياض لاوكرانيا ويربط
محللون الامر بمخاوف تتعلق بالفساد لكن
حتى بعض الجمهوريين الداعمين لاوكرانيا في
مجلس الشيوخ يلتقون ايضا مع مكارتي بشان
المده الزمنيه لهذا الدعم مثل السيناتور
حسنا يجب ان يخسر بوتين لكن الكونجرس لن
يمنح اوكرانيا شيكا على بياض الى الابد
موقف لا يتفق معه الديمقراطيون حسب ما
اوضحت السيناتور
على بياض لاوكرانيا دعمناهم محاولين توفير
الاسلحه التي يحتاجونها وهم مستعدون
لاستخدامه في هذه المعركه
بدورهم انتقد زعيم الجمهوريين في مجلس
الشيوخ متمكن المن وصفهم بالعدد القليل من
اعضاء حزبه المعارضين لدعم اوكرانيا مؤكدا
ان غالبيه الجمهوريين في الكونغرس تدعم
استمرار المساعده لاوكرانيا وتقديم المزيد
لها حتى تنتصر
انه يبدو لم يفعل ما يكفي بسرعه لو كان
يتحرك بسرعه اكبر لربما تمكنا من مساعده
الاوكرانيين على تحقيق نجاح اكبر لكن يبدو
ان انظمه الاسلحه تصل بعد فوات الاوان
الكلمه الفصل في دعم الكونجرس لاوكرانيا
تكمن في مواقف قادته ورؤساء اللجان وكبار
اعضائها حيث يبدو واضحا تاييد الحزبين بل
وتزايد المطالب بتزويدها بطائرات مقاتله
بعد الاعلان عن ارسال دبابات لها
حسين الطاوض العربيه واشنطن
ومشاهدينا بهذا تنتهي هذه الساعه ولكن
التغطيه ما تزال مستمره لهذا اليوم 24 من
فبراير قبل عام اندلعت الحرب في اوكرانيا
نواصل تسليط الضوء على اهم محطات هذا
العام ومالات هذه الحرب الى اين ستستمر
الحرب التي غيرت العالم في الساعه المقبله
تلقاكم الزميله رشا نبيل اعودوا القاكم
عند الثامنه بتوقيت جيف
[موسيقى]